Traduttore: Maurizio Berti
(Applausi)
Buonasera signore e signori,
è un grande onore
essere qui con voi stasera,
e anche una grande sfida per me:
non sono mai stata brava
ad esprimermi con le parole,
io l'ho sempre fatto disegnando.
Sono un'artista,
e quello che abbiamo appena visto
è il racconto per immagini
del mio modus operandi,
cioè il procedimento creativo
e produttivo delle mie opere.
L'artista, secondo me, è una creatura
che vede e sente il mondo e la vita
in maniera speciale, diversa dagli altri,
e ne elabora i messaggi, gli stimoli
interiormente per mezzo del proprio dono,
per poi rimetterli al mondo e alla vita
sotto forma di oggetti, prodotti,
azioni o pensieri artistici
che possono toccare la sfera emotiva
e quella estetica.
L'artista nasce artista,
non è né bene né male,
è così - punto.
Sono qui stasera perché
non mi considero soltanto un'artista,
piuttosto una sorta
di servizio sociale artistico.
Io mi esprimo per mezzo
dello strumento arte,
che a sua volta usa me come strumento,
per poi donare un messaggio
al mondo, che è sociale,
che aiuta me sicuramente,
ma che tenta di aiutare il prossimo.
Non parlerò di arte stasera, ma di vita,
e delle occasioni e delle opportunità
che essa possiede,
e lo farò con tre punti.
Il primo, è che ognuno di noi possiede
dentro di sé una vocazione, un dono,
grazie al quale può realmente trasformare
- e questo è il secondo punto -
il veleno, che a volte c'è nella vita,
in medicina per l'esistenza.
Io ne sono un esempio concreto.
Sopravvissuta a me stessa,
sono divenuta la mia medicina.
La mia vocazione è quella
di portare un messaggio,
e sostenere le persone,
e lo faccio per mezzo
dell'arte, del mio corpo,
della mia persona e della mia esperienza.
Quindi adesso vi racconterò una storia.
È un po' triste ma, vi anticipo,
ha un finale felice, e sono io il finale.
Mio papà non è d'accordo
che io racconti questa storia
e dice che non è giusto
cercare la compassione nella gente.
C'è il rischio che appaia come vittimismo,
e non è necessario
per avere successo nel proprio mestiere.
Non ha torto, ma con amore rispondo:
papà mio, non racconto questa storia
per vendere più quadri,
o avere fama e successo nel mondo.
No.
Ma per scuotere le coscienze
e sollevare gli animi.
E se anche solo una persona
avrà ispirazione da questa storia,
allora io saprò di essere
sulla giusta strada per la mia missione.
Ebbene signori, mettetevi comodi
perché siete a teatro.
C'era una volta una bambina
di circa sette anni.
Affettuosa, allegra, vivace, spensierata,
un po' come tutti i bambini
di quell'età, più o meno.
Lei giocava, abbracciava tutti
e si fidava del prossimo.
Un giorno questa bambina stava giocando
con gli altri bambini del quartiere
giù in cortile,
quando ad un tratto
si avvicinò una persona, un adulto,
forse il papà o fratello
di uno degli altri bambini, non so.
Ma di sicuro lei si fidava di lui,
perché la prese per mano
e andarono via insieme.
Un gioco nuovo, disse lui,
e la portò sin dentro ad un portone
all'interno del quale
c'era uno spazio buio
separato dal resto da un muretto.
Un gioco nuovo e segreto, continuò lui,
e tu sarai brava
e non lo racconterai a nessuno.
Fidati di me, e poi
ti farò anche un bel regalo.
Si sdraiarono.
Lui iniziò ad accarezzarla dolcemente,
poi iniziò a toccarla,
poi si mise sopra di lei
e respirava forte forte.
Brutto, vero?
Lei non provò dolore, neanche paura:
era un gioco, un gioco segreto.
Ma provò la sensazione di aver fatto
qualcosa di sbagliato.
Non le fece male in quel momento,
non fu una cosa violenta:
non fu uno stupro, fu un abuso.
L'abuso implica
la conoscenza della persona,
e la fiducia in essa.
Io non ho memoria della mia vita
prima dei sette anni.
Mia mamma dice che disegnavo già, prima di
imparare a scrivere, ma io non lo ricordo.
Ricordo la mia vita dai sette anni in poi
e non posso neanche dire
di come sia cambiata
e in base a cosa,
perchè non ho termini di confronto.
Non so come sarebbe stata la mia vita
senza quell'episodio.
So che da quel momento in poi
prese una direzione brutta,
brutta e cattiva.
Si sarebbe auto-alimentata
in maniera esponenziale
di ulteriori abusi, violenze, perversioni
e autolesionismi di ogni tipo,
e vergogna, sensi di colpa.
Perché?
Perché aveva scelto proprio me
in mezzo a tutti quei bambini?
Perché? Forse ero cattiva,
forse allora è stata colpa mia.
Ma dentro di me c'era una fiammella
piccola, ma potente.
La mia vocazione mi permetteva
di trasformare il veleno in medicina.
E cercavo la via giusta, e resistevo.
E disegnavo.
Quell'episodio lo rimossi
per circa dieci anni,
vivendo inspiegabilmente male
ogni istante della mia vita,
sentendomi inadeguata ovunque
e diversa da tutti
- maschi, femmine, coetanei,
insegnanti, amici, genitori, familiari -
Diversa, e cattiva;
ma anche molto buona.
E disegnavo sempre e ovunque,
ma da grande non ebbi il coraggio
di sostenere le mie attitudini,
studiando per esempio
all'Accademia delle Belle Arti.
La paura continua,
la mancanza di coraggio e autostima,
e la certezza di non meritare
un briciolo di felicità,
sono tra le mille conseguenze
delle vittime di abusi sessuali.
Dunque mi iscrissi
alla facoltà di architettura,
più lineare, razionale e sicura.
Bellissima, a Firenze, ed ero brava;
ma infelice, sempre di più,
con un mostro dentro.
Fingevo normalità, mentre l'inferno
cresceva dentro di me.
Con queste doti non potei
che iniziare a fare l'attrice:
cinema, teatro, un talento naturale.
Ma la passione per l'autodistruzione
prese il sopravvento,
pian piano, su tutto.
E non fu difficile per le droghe
entrare nella mia vita,
per spegnere il dolore,
staccare cuore, cervello,
sfidare la vita e la morte.
Droga, dipendenza, continui fallimenti,
sempre più in giù, sempre più in basso..
E ancora abusi e violenze:
odiavo il mio corpo,
odiavo la mia vita
e soprattutto odiavo essere donna.
Ma quella fiammella
continuava a rimanere accesa,
piccola ma splendente.
La mia vocazione mi permetteva di trovare
il bello ovunque fosse nascosto,
e di trasformare l'orrore quotidiano,
il veleno, in medicina.
Tutte le ragazze con cui parlai
in comunità di recupero
- tutte -
avevano subito molestie sessuali
da familiari o amici.
La molestia sessuale su un bambino
lascia un'impronta incolmabile.
Sono stata molto fortunata, io,
perché disegnavo, sempre e ovunque.
Comunità, disintossicazione,
l'amore della mia famiglia,
assistenti sociali, medici,
psichiatri, psicologi...
E ancora tanto amore,
e rigore, e disciplina;
ma soprattutto quella fiammella,
la mia vocazione,
mi sostenevano per resistere,
per non mollare e per rifiorire.
E così, a 33 anni sono risorta:
ho ripreso gli studi universitari;
ho iniziato ad allenare
il corpo e la mente;
ho incontrato la pratica buddista;
ho iniziato a disegnare
per una collezione, una mostra,
la mia prima mostra personale
a Cosenza, nella mia città natale.
Poi Roma, la gavetta, incominciando
a esporre nei caffé, nelle librerie;
poi nelle gallerie d'arte,
in mostre collettive;
finalmente una mostra personale..
tra i vincitori di un importante
concorso d'arte,
poi partecipazioni a fiere d'arte
in Italia e all'estero,
fino all'invito alla Biennale di Venezia.
E poi ancora pubblicazioni, articoli,
tesi di laurea sul mio lavoro,
inviti ad accademie di belle arti
per tenere seminari sul disegno.
Creazione di progetti d'arte
accanto a istituzioni, autori, scrittori,
associazioni che tutelano
i diritti delle donne
vittime di abusi o violenze.
Fino in Australia,
come ambasciatrice dell'arte italiana,
e madrina di un'associazione
che tutela e che supporta
gli scambi artistici tra i due paesi.
Ora è l'arte la mia droga,
è la mia terapia.
E l'amore e il desiderio di diffondere
e portare un messaggio
sono il mio carburante.
Sin da subito l'ho desiderato,
con i miei strumenti,
e nonostante non fossi forte abbastanza.
Non lo sono ancora,
forse non lo sarò mai completamente...
non sarò mai
una persona molto equilibrata
e il temperamento artistico
non aiuta molto,
ma oggi onoro quella fiammella,
che è diventata un fuoco
che arde vigoroso.
Le ombre, il buio, ci sono, ma gestibili,
quasi con cui dialogare...
Sono diversa dagli altri? Sì.
Ma è anche grazie a questa differenza,
e a ciò che mi è accaduto,
che posso sentire gli altri
e valorizzarne il bene e il bello.
Disegno con la penna Bic,
e interpreto con amore
donne bellissime e forti,
in grado di diventare tutto ciò
che realmente desiderano:
dalla Vergine Maria
al David di Michelangelo,
all'uomo Vitruviano,
fino a Dio nell'atto della creazione,
oppure semplicemente sé stesse.
Perché - ed è il terzo punto -
non è facile essere donna,
ancor di più se sei una bambina ferita.
La mia vocazione mi permette
di urlarlo a squarciagola
o sussurrarlo dolcemente.
È difficile essere donna, da sempre:
ma è bellissimo.
È un miracolo che si perpetua ogni giorno,
è un dono.
Ed io con il mio dono
ho l'onore e la responsabilità
di portare un messaggio di forza,
di speranza, di bellezza e di luce.
Sì, si può trasformare
il veleno in medicina.
Ogni accadimento della nostra vita
non fa che sviluppare questa vocazione.
Abbiamo già tutto dentro,
deve solo uscire ed esprimersi.
E le esperienze della nostra vita
sono gli strumenti
per fare esprimere questa vocazione
che è racchiusa dentro ad una ghianda,
ma che contiene già tutto il necessario
per diventare una maestosa quercia.
Non so a quante persone
riuscirò ad arrivare,
a quanti cuori, e quanta luce
riuscirò ad infondere:
di sicuro so che sarei stata
un pessimo architetto.
Si può trasformare il veleno in medicina.
Ognuno di noi con la sua vocazione
può portare un messaggio
con la propria vita,
e ispirare la vita degli altri.
Perché, signore e signori cari,
la vita è sacra, l'infanzia è sacra.
E per me, con la mia esperienza,
non posso che ripetere, e ripetere,
che il corpo della donna
è meraviglioso ed è sacro.
Grazie di cuore.
(Applausi)